immer mehr corona fälle in deutschland
doch wie schütze ich mich vor dem virus
zu den wichtigsten maßnahmen gehört
hände waschen legen sie vor dem waschen
ihren schmuck ab halten sie jetzt die
hände unter fließendes wasser ob das
wasser warm oder kalt ist ist den viren
egal
viel wichtiger ist die dauer waschen sie
ihre hände mindestens 20 bis 30 sekunden
lang seifen sie ihre hände nun ein
die handinnenflächen und die handrücken
die zwischenräume die fingerspitzen und
die nägel vergessen sie die daumen nicht
[Musik]
waschen sie danach die hände unter
fließendem wasser ab vorsicht beim
schließen des wasserhahns hier immer ein
tuch oder den ellenbogen benutzen zum
schluss trocknen sie ihre hände
gründlich ab denken sie auch hier an die
fingerzwischenräume
[Musik]